well clark county is expanding covid
vaccine eligibility for more and more
front line workers we thank you for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez so this will impact
thousands of people that have provided
critical infrastructure throughout the
pandemic
reporter kate houston breaks down who is
now eligible and how they're reacting
here at canyon springs high school in
north las vegas many newly eligible
nevadans showed up to receive the first
dose of the coven 19 vaccine
they say this is crucial to continue
their work in their front
line industries it was a very easy very
positive and
very simple process to get the vaccine
jeff braddock works in distribution for
nevada beverage company
he was one of nearly 2 000 to get their
first coveted 19 vaccination
at the canyon springs high school
vaccine pod my co-workers have been very
concerned
about their proximity to the general
public being in grocery stores and
casinos and restaurants and
and anywhere else that you know the
general public is
and has to be because they need
groceries to survive day to day now
those in distribution manufacturing
airport operations communications
emergency road services
and public transportation all became
eligible for the vaccine
ride share driver john ware says getting
his vaccine is critical
as the state continues to lift
restrictions and welcomes even more
visitors this spring
and summer we have to do and especially
in my profession because i'm picking
people up
every day at least two to three people
in my car
you know probably every five to ten
minutes so why wouldn't i be one of the
first ones
you know as the forerunners to go ahead
and figure this thing out these newly
eligible groups are in addition to
nevadans ages 65
and older health care workers and public
safety groups
kate houston 8 news now by the way those
vaccine appointments can be made through
the southern nevada health district
website
there are various vaccination pods and
clinics really throughout the valley
including there at canyon springs high
school over the next few weeks
the